This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。“绝对真人”。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中展现出的坚韧意志、体能以及抗压能力的种种迹象。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字 TWO 点，请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。欢迎收听《回溯往昔》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧界同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊20世纪80年代那样。84年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《回溯往昔》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《难走的路》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人的心路历程，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。然而，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听并了解《难走的路》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控产下一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《爱之陷阱》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩
he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. This episode feels very timely, very necessary for the moment that I'm in right now. since moving to London, I have found myself becoming very self-centered, a much angrier person.
罚。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《闺蜜们：相信我，宝贝》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客节目中，我们探讨二十岁时经历的巨大变化、重要时刻与人生过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听又一期节目，当然，我们今天要剖析二十岁的心理学。这一期节目感觉非常应景，对于我目前所处的阶段来说也非常必要。自从搬到伦敦以来，我发现自己变得越来越以自我为中心，成了一个脾气暴躁得多的人。
And part of what this has done to me and my personality is that for the first time in a while, every slight thing feels like a personal insult. Every person who is pushing me on the tube, every cancelled plan, even though I know the city is busy, every slightly weirdly worded email, I have become very hypervigilant towards it and ready to really see the worst in people and in situations. And that scares me because that's not like me. That's not the person I am. I think part of being a self-conscious kid was that at some stage I just realized it cost too much to care what others thought about me. And I've operated from that mentality for so long, So to have had this resurgence of this like weird making everything about me, reading into
而这对我以及我的性格所造成的影响之一就是，在很长一段时间里，每一件微不足道的小事都让我觉得是对我个人的侮辱。每一个在地铁里挤我的人，每一个临时取消的计划，尽管我知道这座城市很忙碌，甚至每一封措辞稍微有点奇怪的电子邮件，我都变得对它们极度警惕，随时准备把人和事往最坏的方面想。这让我感到害怕，因为这不像我。这不是我原本的性格。我想，作为一个缺乏安全感的孩子，其中的一部分原因在于，某个阶段我突然意识到，在乎别人对我的看法成本太高了。我带着这种心态生活了很久，所以突然又出现了这种奇怪的、把一切都归咎于我、过度解读
everything, taking it all personally attitude is it's not something I'm interested in. I don't think you guys are particularly interested in it as well. I think we could all use a bit of a psychological breakdown of how to release these feelings because they definitely create significant blockages for us when we start to make everything about ourselves. You know, for starters, it collapses your attention inward. It eats up all your mental resources that could have been devoted to things you actually care about. It makes you ignore valuable information such as feedback and healthy criticism because it all just feels like the same kind of threat. And quite frankly, I think it just makes you miserable. It makes
一切、把什么都当成针对自己的态度，这不是我感兴趣的东西。我想你们大家大概也不是特别感兴趣。我想我们所有人都可以从心理学层面上好好剖析一下，如何释放这些情绪，因为当我们开始把一切都归咎于自己时，它们无疑会给我们的内心制造重大的阻碍。你知道，首先，它会把你的注意力向内收缩。它耗尽了你原本可以投入到你真正关心的事情上的所有精神资源。它让你忽视了有价值的信息，比如反馈和健康的批评，因为这一切感觉都像是同一种威胁。坦率地说，我认为这只会让你痛苦不堪。它让你
you self-conscious. It doesn't make you a nice person to be a real. and that is not something that I'm aspiring to be this year or any year. So today, let's answer the question. Why do we so often place ourselves at the center of things, especially things that have very little to do with us? And why that is the case, why our brains operate in this sometimes annoying fashion, and of course how to stop taking things so personally before,
自我意识过剩。说实话，这并不能让你成为一个可爱的人，而且这也不是我今年或任何一年所期望成为的样子。所以今天，让我们来回答这个问题：为什么我们总是把自己放在事情的中心，尤其是那些跟我们没什么关系的事情？为什么会这样，为什么我们的大脑会以这种有时令人讨厌的方式运转，当然，还有如何在事情变得太严重之前，
I guess it goes too far. Stay with us. So the first thing you need to understand is that your consciousness is built through quite a narrow, subjective lens. You don't experience the world from a bird's eye view where you have equal visibility of everyone's experiences. You experience it from inside, one body behind, one pair of eyes with just one stream of thought and subjective feeling that is running through every single experience that you're having.
不再把事情往心里去。留下来跟我们一起探讨吧。所以你需要明白的第一件事是，你的意识是通过一个相当狭隘、主观的镜头构建出来的。你并不是从上帝视角体验世界的，在这种视角下，你对每个人的经历都有着同等的可见度。你的体验是从内部出发的，身处一个躯体背后，透过一对眼睛，伴随着单一的思想流和主观感受，贯穿于你所经历的每一个事件之中。
It is very reflective of that classic quote. You know, you don't see the world as it is. You see the world as you are. So what that means is that when you're feeling insecure, everything becomes evidence of that insecurity. When we see the worst in people, it's because we're not feeling our best. When we see criticism, it's because our inner critic is already so, allowed. You are your only reference point because that's the only perspective that you have direct
这非常符合那句经典名言。你知道，你看世界不是因为世界是那样的，而是因为你是那样的人。所以这意味着，当你感到没有安全感时，一切都会成为这种不安全感的证据。当我们把人往最坏处想时，是因为我们自身状态不佳。当我们看到批评时，是因为我们内心的批评家已经吵得太响了。你唯一的参考系就是你自己，因为那是你唯一能够直接接触到的
access to. Your needs, your feelings, your interpretation, that becomes urgent and it becomes central by design. And this isn't your brain malfunctioning. This is actually the explicit role of the ego at play. And it's exactly why you have an ego, ego, ego literally being the Latin for I, you have an ego to prioritize you. Now, when we hear the word ego, I think we typically associate it with obviously like egotism and bravado and the loud guy at the bar or like the obnoxious know-it-all person at work or like somebody who's very image obsessed. The ego is actually our sense of self and our sense of self-identity, personal awareness. You don't either have an ego or don't, we all have one. In line with psychodynamic theory, which built on
视角。你的需求、你的感受、你的解读，这些变得紧迫起来，并且在设计上成为了核心。这并不是你的大脑出了故障，这实际上是自我（Ego）在发挥其明确的作用。这也是为什么你拥有自我（ego），ego这个词在拉丁语中字面意思就是“我”，你拥有自我（ego）是为了将你自己置于优先地位。现在，当我们听到“自我（ego）”这个词时，我想我们通常会把它和自我中心主义、虚张声势、酒吧里那个大嗓门的家伙、或者职场上那个讨厌的百晓生、又或者是极度痴迷于形象的人联系在一起。但实际上，自我（ego）指的是我们的自我意识、自我认同感以及个人觉知。你并不是非得有或者没有自我，我们每个人都有。根据建立在弗洛伊德原始思想之上的心理动力学理论，
Freud's original ideas, basically the ego is what balances our unconscious primal desire to be important and to be known and to be seen and to indulge with our moral compass, which is called the super ego. And that, our super ego kind of, I guess, represents our calmer side, the side that acts based on what we are expected to act like. So our ego is actually the thing that's in the middle of those two things. It's the mediator that takes what we really want to do and what we know we should do and finds a nice middle ground. When you start taking something personally, what might be happening is that your ego
基本上，自我（ego）是在我们的无意识原始欲望（即渴望重要、渴望被认可、渴望被看见以及渴望纵情享乐）与我们的道德罗盘（被称为超我，super-ego）之间起到平衡作用。而超我某种程度上代表了我们较为冷静的一侧，也就是根据我们被期望的那样去行事的一侧。所以，自我（ego）实际上是居于这两者中间的东西。它是一个调解者，它拿走我们真正想做的事和我们明知应该做的事，并在两者之间找到一个很好的平衡点。当你开始把某件事往心里去时，可能发生的情况是，你的自我（ego）
cannot manage the roar of the id, the roar of who we think. think we are and that we're at the center of the universe with the super ego, the part of us that says, you know, kind of tone it down and act in accordance with what others expect and how you should act. Now, again, ideally, the ego steps in and it does a really good job. It reality tests, it balances both perspectives, it sees a situation from a healthy standpoint. But when our emotions are high, the ego actually gets a lot less effective in those situations because it takes a lot of effort to fight against instinct and impulse and anger. And when the ego can't mediate well, this is where we often start to jump to conclusions and to feel a certain kind of like rage and resentment
无法驾驭本我（id）的喧嚣——也就是那种认为我们自己是宇宙中心、我们最了不起的喧嚣，同时也无法驾驭超我的喧嚣——也就是我们体内那种提醒你收敛一点、按照他人的期望以及你应该表现的方式去行事的那个部分。现在，再说一次，理想情况下，自我会介入并发挥很好的作用。它会进行现实检验，平衡这两种观点，从健康的立场看待情况。但当我们的情绪高涨时，在这些情况下，自我的效力实际上会大大降低，因为要对抗本能、冲动和愤怒需要付出巨大的努力。而当自我无法进行良好的调解时，这正是我们经常开始妄下结论、并产生某种愤怒和怨恨的时候，
because we take everything personally. Now the situations that are the ripest for assumptions and confusions, are those which are ambiguous and which present a threat. And this is why our reaction often spikes in moments where other people are involved and there is a perceived social threat, whether that is rejection, humiliation, exclusion, disapproval. This is always going to register to us as meaningfully dangerous because of evolution, because of our past. So because of that, it gets shifted up the priority poll because it's tied to something that's precious.
因为我们把一切都归咎于个人。现在，最容易产生假设和混乱的情境，是那些模棱两可且带有威胁性的情境。这就是为什么当其他人参与其中并且存在感知到的社会威胁时，我们的反应往往会急剧飙升，无论是拒绝、羞辱、排挤还是不赞同。由于进化和我们的过去，这些对我们来说总是具有重大危险性的信号。正因为如此，它在优先级排序中被提到了更高位置，因为它与某种珍贵的东西挂钩。
Feeling rejected or humiliated, it's tied to things like acceptance and belonging, things that we really care about. So the irony is we make quick judgments when we'd actually be better off having a more controlled, active thought process because of how important this situation is to us. when someone is short with you, when they're quiet, when they're distracted, your brain basically has to infer what that means for you. And it wants to do that quickly. So what information does it have access to quickly? Your interpretation. Your information. Not all the actual evidence or factors. This is, we know what this is. This is a speed over accuracy trade-off. What gets, I don't know, I don't want to say ignored, but maybe neglected, glazed over,
感到被拒绝或羞辱，这与接受和归属感等事物息息相关，这些都是我们真正关心的事。所以讽刺的是，鉴于这种情况对我们如此重要，当我们本可以进行更受控、更主动的思考过程时，我们却做出了快速的判断。当某人对你冷淡、沉默或分心时，你的大脑基本上必须推断这对你意味着什么。而且它希望快速做到这一点。那么它能快速获取到什么信息呢？你的解读。你的信息。而不是所有的实际证据或因素。这就是——我们知道这是什么——这是一个牺牲准确性以换取速度的权衡。由于我们自身心理捷径的运作，那些被——我不知道，我不想说被忽略，但也许是被忽视、被敷衍带过的内容，
due to the operation of our own mental shortcuts, is empathy, is thinking about other people's mood, is thinking about the internal world they're living in and their past and their interpretation. Because in the moment, it takes a lot of extrapolation and thought process to think about their perspective. what you have to remember, and this is hard, but what you have to remember is that every situation actually has three layers. It has the objective reality of the event. It has the meaning that we assign to the event, and it has the meaning that someone else assigns to the event.
是同理心，是去思考其他人的心情，是去思考他们所生活的内心世界以及他们的过去和他们的解读。因为在当时那种情况下，去思考他们的视角需要大量的推导和思考过程。而你必须记住的是——这很难，但你必须记住的是——每种情况其实都有三个层面。它拥有事件的客观现实，拥有我们赋予事件的意义，以及其他人赋予事件的意义。
The meaning we assign is an appraisal, and our appraisals are rarely and I don't think they're never neutral. We know this from something called cognitive motivational relational theory. And this theory of emotion basically describes and explains how emotions arise through an interaction between our past and how we interpret a situation along with our goals and our values. And then what concerns others and what concerns our well-being. Very complicated way of saying, in other words, our appraisals dictate how we see something. and they are a great peak into what we really fear, what we really want, what we really care about.
我们赋予的意义是一种评估（appraisal），而我们的评估很少——而且我认为绝不可能是中立的。我们从一个叫做认知-动机-关系理论（cognitive motivational relational theory）的概念中了解到这一点。这种情绪理论基本上描述并解释了情绪是如何通过我们的过去与我们对情境的解释之间的相互作用，连同我们的目标和价值观而产生。然后是关乎他人以及关乎我们福祉的事情。换句话说，这是一种非常复杂的说法，即我们的评估决定了我们如何看待某事物。
You've got to remember, again, human behavior is highly complex, it's highly individualized. So we end up relying on shortcuts that have formed in our minds, in our brains over many, many years. So if you have any tender places or sore emotional spots, any old fears, if you encounter a situation that even looks slightly like that. Your brain will try to resolve the ambiguity by snapping that moment onto the nearest familiar story. And that is why normal events begin to feel like you're being attacked, because they match something you already believe could be true. There is another word in psychology for this, schema or schemas. This is the way we organize our current experience based on past experience. Schemotherapy, which was developed, I think only like in the 70s or 80s.
并且它们能很好地让我们一窥我们真正恐惧的是什么，我们真正想要的是什么，我们真正关心的是什么。你必须记住，人类的行为高度复杂，具有高度的个体化。因此，我们最终只能依赖在我们的内心和大脑中经过多年岁月逐渐形成的捷径。所以，如果你有任何脆弱的部位或情绪痛点，任何旧日的恐惧，如果你遇到一个哪怕看起来有点相似的情境。你的大脑就会试图通过将那一刻与最熟悉的故事情节生搬硬套在一起来消除这种模棱两可。这就是为什么普通的事件开始让你觉得你正在遭到攻击，因为它们符合你已经认为可能是真实的东西。在心理学中，对此有另一个词，叫做图式（schema）或图式理论（schemas）。这是我们根据过去的经验来组织当前经验的方式。图式疗法（Schemotherapy），据我所知，它大概是在20世纪70年代或80年代才发展起来的。
Basically what it says is that there are a few main schemers, a few main ways of seeing information that will skew neutral information into a dangerous interpretation based on our past experience. I'm going to describe a few, and you can kind of see what I mean. So, for example, a really common one is an abandonment schema. What that basically means is that the past has told you people are going to leave. People aren't to be trusted. They're unpredictable. They will abandon you.
它基本上是说，有几种主要的图式，即看待信息的几种主要方式，它们会根据我们的过去经验，将中立的信息歪曲成危险的解读。我来描述几种，你们大概就能明白我的意思了。例如，一个非常常见的是被遗弃图式（abandonment schema）。这基本上意味着，过去让你明白：人们会离开。人们是不可信的。他们是不可预测的。他们会抛弃你。
So it essentially says any situation that looks like that is going to be that. And you should be wary of any signs that they're going to leave so that you can prepare to leave first. you have an abandonment schema. Then there is a mistrust schema, kind of similar. You know, this is when the past has really taught you that people will take your shortcomings and use them against you. So you shouldn't give people the ammo to kind of do so. Another well-known one is a shame schema. This is when in the past, you know, you've revealed certain things about yourself and people have blamed you,
所以它本质上是在说，任何看起来像这样的情况都将是那样。你应该对他们即将离开的任何迹象保持警惕，这样你才能准备先一步离开。这就是你拥有被遗弃图式时的表现。接下来是不信任图式（mistrust schema），有点类似。你知道，当过去真正教导你：人们会抓住你的缺点并用来对付你时，就会产生这种图式。所以你不应该给别人提供这样做的弹药。另一个广为人知的是羞耻图式（shame schema）。这是指在过去，你知道，你向别人暴露了关于你自己的某些事情，而人们却责备你，
made you feel bad, criticized you, so now you learn to keep. parts of your identity to yourself. One final one, the failure to achieve a schema. I actually think this one is very interesting. This is a situation where because you have failed in the past, you inevitably now believe that you will continue to fail again into the future. Therefore, this is an indication that you are untalented, you are not successful, and you should never try.
让你感觉糟糕，批评你，所以现在你学会了把自我身份的某些部分隐藏起来。最后一个，未能成就图式（failure to achieve schema）。我实际上觉得这个非常有趣。这是一种这样的情况：因为你过去曾经失败过，所以你不可避免地现在相信你在未来还会继续失败。因此，这表明你是一个没有才华的人，你是不成功的，你永远不应该去尝试。
There are, I think, from Jeffrey Young's original work, there's about 18 schemers. So you can go and look these up and there is one for literally every single situation. Another one is the pessimism schema, like believing that life will always return to being bad, therefore anything good will soon be taken away. You shouldn't trust anything. I know one of my own schemas I have to be aware of is social isolation schema. You know, I've talked about this.
我想，从杰弗里·扬（Jeffrey Young）的原创工作来看，大约有18种图式。所以你们可以去查阅这些，几乎每一种具体情境都对应着一种图式。另一种是悲观主义图式（pessimism schema），比如坚信生活总会变回糟糕的样子，因此任何美好的事物很快都会被夺走。你不应该信任任何东西。我知道我必须注意的其中一个图式是我自己的社交隔离图式（social isolation schema）。你知道的，我谈过这个。
I had a really hard time when I was a kid. I was bullied really badly. Nowadays, I know that means my brain is always going to read too much. into small social slights or silence from friends. I know that because in these situations, I always feel like a kid again, and I always have this urge to panic, to withdraw, to get angry, and it means that I take neutral situations,
我小时候经历过一段非常艰难的时期。我被欺凌得很惨。如今，我知道这意味着我的大脑总是会对朋友们小小的社交冷落或沉默做出过度解读。我知道这一点，因为在这种情况下，我总是觉得自己又回到了小时候，我总是有一种想要恐慌、想要退缩、想要生气的冲动，这意味着我会把中立的情境，
and I make them about me in a very unique way, a very individualized way based on my past hurt. We all do this. So if you want to stop taking things too seriously or personally, You firstly need to understand the schema. You need to understand, should I actually say, the scheme is plural, that you are bringing to the table. Being aware of that is so crucial so that you can interrupt that self-focused rationalization of neutral events and have a more healthy positive interpretation. That is my first step for taking things less personally.
以一种非常独特、非常个性化的方式，根据我过去的创伤，转化成与我有关的事情。我们所有人都会这样做。所以，如果你想停止把事情看得太严重或太私人化，你首先需要了解图式。你需要理解，或者更准确地说，应该是复数的图式，是你带到台面上的那些图式。意识到这一点至关重要，这样你才能打断那种对中立事件的自我中心式合理化，从而产生更健康、更积极的解读。这是我提出的减少把事情往心里去的第一步。
But we are going to take a short break here and then dive into a few others. stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
不过我们在这里要稍作休息，然后深入探讨其他几点。请留步。《2%》。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代社会中展现出的坚韧意志、体能以及抗压能力的种种迹象。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和体能专家等人进行对话，抛开那些统治着健康产业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 T-W-O-Persent，请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of America. crack.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回溯往昔》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为美国。还有快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时准备在白天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。欢迎在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《回溯往昔》。欢迎收听我的新播客《难走的路》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐之中，以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了这样东西。而我们却仍在追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要，还是你当一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地成为一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《难走的路》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learning a hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
打开你免费的iHeartRadio App，搜索《难走的路》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要动用一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯平与迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《爱之陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食其果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这还没完……请收听《爱之陷阱》播客，
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice of... served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two,
也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜们》的这个新季节里，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。请收听《闺蜜们：
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
相信我，宝贝》。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。我相信我们都有点厌倦听到这个了，但是当你开始把事情太当回事时，有时你需要被提醒一下事实。而事实表明，除了他们自己之外，其他人的时间和注意力很少会放在别的事情上。简而言之，根本没人想着你。他们想的都是他们自己。当他们想到你，或者当他们想到与你的一次互动时，
Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm sure we are all kind of sick of hearing this, but when you start taking things too personally, sometimes you need a reminder of the facts. And the facts say very little of other people's time is concerned with anything but themselves. Simply put, nobody's thinking about you. They're thinking about them. And when they are thinking about you or they are thinking about an interaction they've had with you,
通常他们脑子里想的都是他们自己那一边的故事。以下两项研究为这一现象提供了实实在在的证据。第一项研究来自可以说是世界上最著名的社会心理学家。在这个播客里，你听到他名字的次数可能比听到我名字的次数还要多。罗宾·邓巴（Robin Dunbar），我梦寐以求的嘉宾。他在90年代进行了这项研究，他分析了成千上万个人的对话，并将这些对话进行编码分类，比如：人们谈论自己与谈论他人的频率分别是多少？
often they're thinking about their own side of the story. Here are two studies that provide literal evidence for this being the case. The first is from possibly the most famous social psychologist in the world. You will have heard his name on this podcast probably more than my own. Robin Dunbar, my dream guest. He conducted this study in the 90s where he analyzed the conversations of thousands of individuals and he coded the conversations to be like, how often are people talking about themselves versus others?
他发现，在我们所有的对话中，有78%涉及人们谈论自己以及他们自己的看法。那么，简单心算一下，留给我们的对话还剩多少？只有22%的对话是我们真正在谈论其他人的。2021年的另一项类似研究，实际上对2000多名参与者进行了八项实验，结果发现：尽管有时我们可能低估了别人想我们的程度，但当别人想到我们时，他们依然是自身思维的中心。他们会反复回味自己说了什么、做了什么、感受如何。如果不是某种与他们切身相关的事情，他们大概连你今天穿的是什么衣服都说不出来。不过，说到证据，确实有一项专门针对这个确切想法的研究。
And he found that 78% of all of our conversations involved people talking about themselves and their own perceptions. That leaves only what, quick math? 22% of conversations where we are talking about other people. A similar study from 2021, ran eight experiments actually with over 2,000 people and found that even if we sometimes underestimate
在2000年代初，康奈尔大学的研究人员让参与者穿上一件印有尴尬、粗俗或搞笑图像的T恤，站在整个班级面前。在他们走进去之前，研究人员问参与者：“你觉得有多少人会注意到你穿了这件糟糕透顶、极其尴尬的T恤？”
how much people are thinking about us, when people are thinking about us, again, they still remain the centre of their own thoughts. They replay what they said, what they did, how they felt. They probably couldn't tell what outfit you were wearing if it wasn't something that was personally related to them. But evidence to evidence here, there was a study on literally that exact idea.
参与者回答说：“我觉得大概有50%的人会注意到我的T恤。”但实际上，只有大约25%，只有大约四分之一的同班同学真正注意到了那些T恤。即便如此，他们也未必对它抱有负面看法。停止把事情往心里去的一个绝佳方法是记住：别人其实根本没那么在乎你。他们对你的关注少之又少。这可能是最让人感到害怕的想法之一，
In the early 2000s, researchers at Cornell University asked participants to wear a t-shirt with like an embarrassing, crude, funny image in front of the entire class. And before they went in, researchers asked the participants, like, how many people do you think are going to notice that you're wearing this terrible, terrible, embarrassing shirt?
但我也认为这是最赋能的想法之一。我们之所以沉迷于别人的看法和对我们的感知，部分原因是因为我们相信所谓的聚光灯效应（spotlight effect）。该效应认为，你对自己极为厌恶、感到缺乏自信、并且每次照镜子时第一眼看到的那件事，
The participants were like, I think around 50% of people are going to notice my t-shirt. But actually, it was only around 25%, only about 25% of their fellow classmates actually noticed the t-shirts. And even then they didn't necessarily have negative opinions of it. A great way to stop taking things personally is to remember, people don't care about you that much. They care very little about you. That can be one of the most terrifying thoughts.
其他人身上也有一道聚光灯照着它，他们也能看得到。问题在于，其他人体验到的你，只是众多刺激中的一个刺激，它与那些对他们来说更加紧迫的事情并存，比如他们自己的担忧、他们自己的压力，以及他们聚光灯下所认为的——你正在如何看待他们的那种感觉。聚光灯效应基本上是大脑在逻辑上犯下的一个错误。它在说：“因为我注意到了，所以其他人肯定也能注意到。”而心理学研究表明：大概并非如此。即便他们确实注意到了，而且这成为了他们注意力的中心，难道这不更能说明他们自身的问题吗？说明他们能够以如此高的准确度去指出别人的不安全感？我只是觉得，如果有人能在面前的一群人中做到这一点，并且能够指出：“你对那个特征感到不安全，你对那个特征感到不安全，”
and I also think one of the most empowering. Part of why we obsess over people's opinions and their perceptions of us is because we believe in this so-called spotlight effect, which says that the thing you dislike deeply about yourself, that you are insecure about, that you see the first thing, it's the first thing you see when you look in the mirror.
这更能说明他们自己的问题。所以这就是我给出的建议：要想停止把事情往心里去，首先要识别出你是如何过度解读事情的，但同时也要认清：你对于别人注意到你的事情往往有多么不准确，以及你在自己身上发现的那个问题对其他人来说其实多么微不足道。接下来，因为这绝对是那种有时人们觉得很难付诸实践的建议。我肯定也觉得很难付诸实践。
Everybody else there is a spotlight on it, they can see it too. The thing is, other people are experiencing you as just one stimulus amongst many other stimuli, alongside things that are much more pressing to them, such as their own worries and their own stress and their own spotlight on what they think you're seeing in them. The spotlight effect is basically your brain making an error in logic. It's saying, because I notice it, it must be noticeable to everybody else as well. The psychology says probably not. And even if they do notice it, and it is the center of their attention, isn't it more indicative of them that they're able to pinpoint somebody else's insecurities with
我们是具有社交敏感度的生物，并不是说我们听到这些事实就会觉得：“太好了，我被治愈了。”相反，如果你发现自己很难停止把事情往心里去，我认为你不需要停止在意所有人的意见。相反，我希望你只挑选四个人，这四个人的意见对你来说才真正重要。这四个人的评论，你才允许自己往心里去。这四个人的意见，你才会认真采纳。只有四个。
that much accuracy? I just feel like that's a, if somebody's able to do that for a group of people in front of them and is able to be like, you're insecure about that feature, you're insecure about that feature. That says so much more about them. So that's my tip here. to stop taking things personally, identify, yes, how you may be reading into things, but then also identify how often you're probably incorrect about what other people are noticing about you and how little a problem that you have with yourself is to everybody else. Next, because this is definitely sometimes advice people find it hard to practice. I definitely find it hard to practice this.
你只能选四个，所以你必须明智地选择。而且这些人是不能被替换下去的。他们是不能被随意换进换出的。他们将一直在这个团队里，直到他们被永久踢出团队。你的第二个规则是：他们必须是你真正信任其意见、并且你知道他们会坚定支持你的人。如果你的母亲总是挑剔你的选择，你不能选你的母亲。如果你的老板总是对你不尊重并让你哭泣，你不能选你的老板。
We are socially attuned. it's not like we're going to hear these facts and be like, great, I'm cured. Instead, if you're finding it hard to stop taking things personally, I don't think you have to stop caring about everyone's opinions. Instead, I want to ask that you pick only four people whose opinions matter to you. Four people whose comments you allow yourself to take personally. Four people whose opinions you take on board. Only four.
你不能选择一个总是贬低你的朋友。我希望你挑选由朋友、家人或伴侣组成的四人团队，只有他们的意见你才被允许往心里去，除此之外的任何人都不行。我真的很喜欢这个方法，因为你很可能已经花了15、20年甚至更长的时间去吸收所有人的想法或对你的潜在看法。所以你不可能在一夜之间扭转这种习惯。你不可能一下子就彻底不在乎他们的想法。这就像是你可能需要的替代疗法。
You can only choose four, so you have to choose wisely. And these people cannot be subbed out. They cannot be subbed in. They are on the team until they are permanently off the team. And your second rule is that they have to be somebody whose opinion you truly trust and who you know has your back. You can't choose your mom if your mom always criticizes your choices. You can't choose your boss if your boss always disrespects you and makes you cry.
你知道，与其彻底戒掉把事情往心里去的习惯，不如我们稍微减少一点。我们只是减少剂量。我认为，如果你觉得很难不把自己代入某个故事中，那么另一个停止把事情往心里去的办法，其实是把自己更深地代入进去。这听起来会非常——这虽然是很简单的建议，但它很重要。你需要用你知道自己会有的想法，来打断你对“他们脑海里在想什么”的解读。再说一次，我们只能接触到我们自己的想法。利用这一点为自己谋取优势。如果是你在这种情况下，在他们的情况下，你实际上会怎么看待这件事？
Can't choose a friend who always puts you down. I want you to choose your team of four, a friends, family, a partner whose opinions you are allowed to take personally and then nobody else outside of that. I really like this method because you've most likely spent 15, 20 plus years absorbing everybody's thoughts or potential thoughts about you. So you aren't going to be able to reverse that overnight. You're not going to be able to go cold turkey on caring what they think. This is like the replacement therapy you may need.
你知道，你为什么会做出那样的判断？你为什么会用那种语气说话？如果你有三个截止日期，如果你头痛，前一晚没睡好，并且（你知道的）你还在担心报税的事，我不知道，你在发信息时的语气会听起来是怎样的？如果你真的精疲力竭，你是会表现得热情健谈，还是会简短而安静？如果你真的很焦虑、不知所措，你是会表现得完美无瑕，还是会有点心不在焉？
you know, instead of going sober from taking things personally, we just go down a little bit. We just decrease the dosage. I think another way to stop taking things so personally, if you find it hard to not insert yourself into a story, is actually to insert yourself even further. It's going to be so, this is such simple advice, but it's important. you need to interrupt your interpretation of what you think they're thinking with what you know you would be thinking. Again, we only have access to our own thoughts. Use that to your advantage. If this was you in this situation, in their situation, how would you actually be thinking about this?
你会如何表现和反应？问自己这个问题，把自己更深地代入到叙事中，可以通过思考“为什么别人会被迫做出这种反应”或者“这里还可能有什么是真的”，来帮助你摆脱“这对你意味着什么”的陷阱。这其实是一种经典的缓解焦虑的小贴士。当然，我们之所以把事情往心里去，很大程度上是因为焦虑，是用我们自己的认知和最坏的情况去填补空白。
You know, why would you have made that judgment? Why would you have spoken in that tone? You know, if you had three deadlines, if you had a headache, and had a bad night's sleep and, you know, you were worried about tax time, I don't know, how would you come off as sounding in a message? If you were really socially drained, would you be warm and chatty, or would you be brief and quiet? If you were really anxious, overwhelmed, would you show up perfectly, or would you be a little bit distracted?
但这种技术——连锁反应打断法，要求你在问“万一……怎么办（what if）”之前，先去质疑“还可能有什么（what else）”。这里还可能发生着什么别的事情呢？一个好的法则是：当你发现你的大脑开始带着假设胡思乱想时，每一个负面的假设，你都必须给自己一个正面的假设。你必须实现“万一”与“还可能”的一对一比例。第四个小建议。我想我们现在已经讲到第四个了吧。
How would you be behaving and reacting? Asking yourself this, putting yourself even further into the narrative, can help pull you out of the trap of what this means for you by thinking why has somebody else been kind of forced or has had this reaction? What else could be true here? It's actually kind of a classic anxiety tip. And of course, a lot of why we take things personally is anxiety and is filling the gaps with our own knowledge and the worst case scenario.
我不知道。如果我记错了请纠正我。把那些属于假设的事情和你知道是事实的事情贴上标签。这是阻止那些螺旋式胡思乱想的好方法。当你开始把事情往心里去时，你的大脑正在将事实和解读混为一谈。它将它们天衣无缝地混在了一起。它们感觉就像是同一回事。你对这种情况的感受，一定成了唯一的准确解读。
But this technique, this chain reaction interruption, asks you to question what else before you ask what if. What else could be going on here? A good rule, when you find your brain running away with assumptions, for every negative assumption, you have to give yourself a positive one. You have to achieve a one-to-one ratio of what if and what else. Tip number four. I think we're up to number four now.
试着把这两件事拆开。也许，让我们用这个例子：比如你的朋友取消了你们计划好的晚饭。这里的假设可能是：哦，这完全证明了他们不再喜欢我了。他们不在乎我了。他们觉得我很烦。他们打算甩掉我。而这里的事实仅仅是：他们取消了。另一个事实可能是：他们真的没有精力了，或者他们确实生病了。或者也许有人没有回复信息。这里的假设可能是：他们在躲着你，或者他们不想跟你说话，或者他们对你感到恼火。但事实是，如果我们剔除掉所有
I don't know. Correct me if I'm wrong. label the things that are assumptions and the things that you know are facts. This is a great one to stop those spiraling thoughts. When you start to take things personally, your brain is mixing facts and interpretations. It's mixing them together so seamlessly. They feel like they're the same thing. How you feel about the situation must be the only accurate interpretation.
我不知道。如果我错了，请纠正我。把那些假设的事情和你知道是事实的事情区分开来。这是一个阻止那些螺旋式上升的想法的好方法。当你开始把事情当作针对自己时，你的大脑正在把事实和解释混为一谈。它们混合得如此天衣无缝，以至于你觉得它们是同一回事。你对这种情况的感觉一定是最准确的解释。
Try and pull these two things apart. Maybe, let's use the example. of like your friend cancels a dinner that you had planned. An assumption here would be that, oh, this is totally evidence they don't like me anymore. They don't care about me. They think I'm annoying. They're going to ditch me. The fact here is simply that they canceled. Another fact might be that they genuinely just don't have the mental capacity or that they really are sick. Or maybe someone doesn't reply. The assumption here might be that they're avoiding you or that they don't want to talk to you or that they're annoyed at you. But the facts, the facts are, if we remove all
试着把这两件事拆开。也许，我们来举个例子。比如你的朋友取消了你们计划好的晚餐。这里的假设会是，哦，这完全证明了他们不再喜欢我了。他们不在乎我。他们觉得我很烦。他们打算甩掉我。这里的事实仅仅是他们取消了。另一个事实可能是他们真的没有心理承受能力，或者他们确实生病了。或者也许有人没有回复。这里的假设可能是他们在躲避你，或者他们不想跟你说话，或者他们生你的气了。但事实是，如果我们去除所有
the emotion and fear-driven thoughts from this situation, it's just that they haven't replied. There are so many other possible explanations here. Acknowledging the assumptions versus the facts helped you to acknowledge the story you're telling yourself versus the reality of the story that's much more complex and has multiple perspectives to it. Next tip, tip number five, remember that this feeling you're having is temporary, but your reaction to the feeling can make the moment permanent. I just think it's wise to always try and give people the benefit of the doubt because that alone will reduce your emotional suffering. If for nothing else, it just means that you don't have to go through the annoyance
这种情境下产生的由情绪和恐惧驱动的想法，其实只是对方还没回复而已。这里还有很多其他可能的解释。分辨出假设与事实的区别，能帮助你意识到你脑补的故事和故事现实之间的差距。现实要复杂得多，并且有多种不同的视角。下一个技巧，第五个技巧，记住，你现在的这种感觉是暂时的，但你对这种感觉的反应却会让这个时刻变得持久。我认为，总是尽量去选择相信别人是明智的，因为仅此一点就能减少你的精神内耗。如果说没有别的什么原因，至少这意味着你不需要去经历那种烦恼
and the frustration of taking something personally multiple times. This one is pretty huge because often we will have this overwhelming response or this overwhelming urge to respond immediately, to fix something, to correct something, to defend yourself, to pull away. And I get it. Again, it's this threat detection system, which is trying to close the gap of uncertainty so that we know that we're going to survive and we know what to do next. But the thing is, feelings and emotions pass. They are uncomfortable. They will leave eventually.
以及因多次把事情对号入座而带来的挫败感。这一点非常重要，因为通常我们会产生一种强烈的反应，或者说有一种迫切的冲动想要立即回应、去修复什么、纠正什么、为自己辩护、或者选择退缩。我懂的。再说一次，这是我们的威胁检测系统在起作用，它试图缩小不确定性的差距，好让我们知道自己能活下来，并且知道接下来该做什么。但问题是，感觉和情绪是会过去的。它们虽然让人不舒服，但最终都会离开。
But if you act on these emotions and you send a really reactive text or you, somebody pushes you and you push them back or something like that, you make a passive aggressive comment or you shrink yourself or you escalate the situation into something that is bigger, that's going to create lasting tension, lasting stress. and it's going to make the assumption you had the fact. It's going to turn the assumption into reality when it wasn't that way to begin with. Just give the emotion, give that initial reaction,
但如果你顺着这些情绪采取行动，发了一条充满情绪化的短信，或者别人推了你一下你又推回去之类的事情，或者你说了句阴阳怪气的话，或者你自我贬低，又或者把事情升级成更大的矛盾，这就会造成持久的紧张和持久的压力，并且会把你的假设变成事实。它会把原本并非如此的假设变成现实。给情绪一点空间，给那种最初的反应
some space to just like move through you before you turn it, before you create collateral damage. Acknowledge that you might actually be wrong about the situation. Acknowledge that you might not have all the information yet and give people the benefit of the doubt before making the situation more intense. Something that goes hand in hand with this, and this is some of my best advice, the best advice I've ever received from somebody was
一些缓冲的时间，让它在你的体内流转消散，而不是在它变成你造成的连带损害之前去盲目应对。承认你对这个情况的看法可能其实是错的。承认你可能还没掌握全部信息，并且在把局势升级之前，选择相信别人。与此相辅相成的一点——这也是我给出的最好的建议之一，我从别人那里收到的最好的建议——那就是
when you truly believe that someone's perception of you is negative, honestly, regardless of that, the best thing you can do, whether they're a stranger, a random person, is to be sickeningly nice and kind to them. That is actually the best response you can have, because then they have no choice, but to look at your behavior and see your positive reaction and see how nice you're being to them and only see a mirror of what they should be acting like and how ridiculous their behavior actually is. A study published last summer, I believe, at the University of Oregon, found really sizable evidence for this working.
当你真诚地相信某人对你的看法是负面的时，老实说，抛开这些不谈，你能做的最好的事情，无论是面对陌生人还是随便什么人，就是对他们好到让人发指的程度。这其实是你所能做出的最好回应，因为那样的话，他们就别无选择，只能看着你的行为，看到你的积极反应，看到你对他们有多好，并且只能看到一面镜子，映照出他们本该如何行事，以及他们自己的行为实际上有多么荒谬。去年夏天，我想是在俄勒冈大学发表的一项研究，发现了支持这一做法的非常实质性的证据。
They called it the perceiver elicited similarity effect. Basically, our behavior elicits similar behavior in others by setting a social standard that they then self-police on. You take people out of their world, you bring them into your world, and you make your world a pleasant place to be, one that has the kindness you wish to treat others by and you wish they treated you with. I think this has a bleed-on effect in that it allows us to detach from others' opinions because our internal world feels so stable and sound. If you make your internal world a positive one and you try and bring people in, when they still decide that they're going to
他们称之为“旁观者引出的相似性效应”。基本上，我们的行为通过设定一个社会标准，从而在他人身上引发相似的行为，他们会用这个标准来自我约束。你把人们带出他们的世界，带入你的世界，把你的世界变成一个宜居的地方，一个充满你希望用来对待他人、也希望他人用来对待你的善良的地方。我认为这会产生一种溢出效应，它能让我们从他人的意见中抽离出来，因为我们的内心世界感觉如此稳定和健全。如果你让你的内心世界变得积极，并试图把别人也带进来，当他们仍然决定要
ruin the moment for you or they are going to personally project opinions on you, frankly, you don't, it's not a problem for you. It's not your business because your life and your internal state of being and your mindset is so strong and so positive that what are they trying to achieve? Sometimes when I'm really getting pulled into thinking about what others may think, do say how they perceive me, I try and think of myself as just another part of nature. I try and think of myself like a tree or a mountain or a bird. The job of nature and of these things is just to exist without narration. They don't audition.
毁掉你的时刻，或者执意要把他们对你的看法强加在你身上时，坦白说，你不会觉得这是个问题。这不关你的事，因为你的生活、你的内在状态和你的心态是如此强大和积极，他们到底在试图达到什么目的呢？有时，当我真的陷入去思考别人可能会怎么想、怎么做、怎么说、他们是如何看待我的时候，我试着把我自己想象成大自然的一部分。我试着把自己想象成一棵树、一座山或一只鸟。大自然和这些东西的职责只是存在，而无需任何旁白。它们不需要去试镜。
They don't care. They don't imagine what story people are telling about them. They are just there to exist. And visualizing myself as just another part of nature, which I am, which we all are, whose goal is just to experience and to exist is very uniquely grounding because it gives you that cognitive distance between the situation and your interpretation, and it lets you just, it lets you just exist and not take it all on board. My final advice, if all else fails, remember the rule of five. Will it matter in five days? Will it matter in five months? Will it
它们不在乎。它们不会去想象别人在编造关于它们的什么故事。它们就在那里存在着。把自己想象成自然的一部分——事实上也确实如此，我们所有人都是如此——我们的目标仅仅是体验和存在，这种想法具有一种独特的基础力量，因为它在情况和你的解读之间创造了认知距离，让你能够去顺其自然，只是存在，而不要把所有事情都往心里去。我最后的建议是，如果其他方法都失效了，记住五的法则。这在五天后还重要吗？这在五个月后还重要吗？这在
matter in five years. I think modern day society and the kind of systems we exist in make everything feel very urgent and enormous and significant and life ending. So it's important to ask yourself this question to give you a good perspective. If it's not going to matter in five years, you don't need to burn your sense of self to the ground over it. If it's not going to matter in five years, you shouldn't spend more than five minutes worrying about it. have that short amount of time, that five minutes to worry and to stress if you really need to, and then just commit to writing the wave and letting it go. If you actually think, yeah, it's going to matter in five months, it's going to matter in five years,
五年后还重要吗？我认为现代社会以及我们所处体制让每件事都显得非常紧急、巨大、意义重大且攸关生死。因此，问自己这个问题以获得一个良好的视角是很重要的。如果它在五年内不再重要，你就不需要为此把你的自我意识付之一炬。如果它在五年内不再重要，你就不应该花超过五分钟的时间去为它烦恼。给自己留出那么短的一点时间——那五分钟去焦虑、去压力（如果真的有必要的话），然后就承诺顺应波澜，随它去吧。如果你真的觉得，是的，这在五个月后很重要，这在五年后很重要，
then it deserves a calm conversation between you and the other person. Then it deserves more of a time investment. You know, it might be pointing to something bigger. There might be a pattern at play here. there might be a boundary you've been avoiding. Having that litmus test of like which of these three categories, five days, five months, five years is this going to fall into, lets you appropriately scale your response.
那么它就值得你和另一个人进行一次冷静的对话。那么它就值得你投入更多的时间。你知道的，这可能指向更严重的问题。这里可能存在某种模式，或者可能存在一个你一直在回避的边界。有了这样一个试金石，看看这属于五天、五个月还是五年这三个类别中的哪一个，就能让你对自己的反应做出适当的调整。
This just gives you an opportunity to, I think, put things into perspective, assign your response based on an honest assessment rather than treating everything like life or death. And I think if you strip it all down, all these skills, what we're really asking ourselves to do is to firstly recognize that this may be an interpretation and that your interpretation may be different to theirs. And then to secondly put it into perspective, how much does this really matter? And what is going to cost me more here?
这刚好能让你有机会，我认为，去把事情看透，根据诚实的评估来决定你的反应，而不是把每件事都当成生死攸关的大事。我想如果你把这一切剥丝抽茧，所有这些技能，我们真正要求自己做的事情是：首先，认识到这可能只是一种解读，而你的解读可能与他们的不同；其次，把它放在合适的角度去权衡——这到底有多重要？在这里什么会让我付出更大的代价？
Taking this personally, taking it on board, having a reaction. to it or just letting it go and choosing to stay curious, choosing to be like nature, choosing to remove myself from the narrative. If that person's opinion is still going to be the same, and you're not going to be able to change it, if their opinion is really that, isn't this going to be the best case choice regardless? Isn't that level of dignity over panic going to lead you to a better place? anyway, it's just such a rational choice and maybe that's what we're really aiming for here,
把这当作针对自己、把这放在心上、对此做出情绪反应，还是放手并选择保持好奇、选择像大自然一样、选择将自己从叙事中抽离出来？如果那个人的意见仍然不会改变，而你也无法改变它，如果他们的意见真的是那样，难道不管怎样，这都不是最优的选择吗？难道那种超越恐慌的尊严感不会引导你走向一个更好的结果吗？不管怎样，这都是一个非常理性的选择，也许这才是我们在这里真正追求的目标：
a rational choice in the face of irrationality that's going to leave you better off. So I hope these tips have helped you. I hope this psychological explanation for why we insert ourselves into narratives we don't belong in. It's clarifying for you. And that it just gives you pause, right? when you're in a situation like this next, you're able to really be like, work your way through the choices. It's like a build your own adventure. You're able to work your way through the adventure and be like, okay, even if this person is thinking this, is it in my best interest to take it on board? Or is it in my
在非理性面前做出理性的选择，这会让你过得更好。所以我希望这些技巧对你们有所帮助。我希望这个心理学解释——关于为什么我们要把自己代入本不属于我们的故事中——能对你有所启发。并且它能让你停下来，对吧？当你下次再遇到这种情况时，你能够真正地像这样，去理清各种选择。这就像是一本“选择你自己的冒险”的书。你能够在这场冒险中找到自己的出路，然后心想：好吧，即使这个人是这么想的，把这当回事符合我的最大利益吗？还是说
best interest to discard this? Or to bring them into a nicer world, the one that I choose to inhabit. If you have made it this far, thank you for being a loyal listener. You now get access to our little secret, our secret club where you can drop a little nature emoji down below. So I know that you have made it this far and that you have listened to the end. Nature emoji because I think that's the ultimate goal of this episode, be more like nature. I also want to thank, of course, our researcher Libby Colbert for her assistance on this episode. Make sure that if you are listening and you are in the US, you check us out on Netflix because video episodes are now screening over there.
把这抛在脑后才符合我的最大利益？或者把他们带入一个更美好的世界，带入我所选择居住的世界。如果你坚持听到了这里，感谢你作为一个忠实的听众。你现在可以进入我们的小秘密，我们的秘密俱乐部，你可以在下方留下一个小小的大自然表情符号。这样我就知道你已经坚持听到了最后，并且听完了整期节目。大自然表情符号，因为我认为这才是本期节目的终极目标，变得更像大自然。当然，我也要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的协助。如果你在收听节目并且身在美国，请务必去 Netflix 上关注我们，因为视频版节目现在正在那边播映。
and we'd love for you to watch and to see what the vibe is like and what it's like being in the studio with me, rather than just listening, but of course, it is up to you. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram and also on Substack if you want access to more studies. All those links will be down below. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon.
我们很希望你能去观看，看看氛围是怎样的，看看跟我一起在录音室里是什么体验，而不只是单纯地收听，当然，这完全取决于你。也请确保你在 Instagram 上关注我们，如果你想获取更多研究资料，也可以关注我们的 Substack。所有这些链接都会在下方列出。但直到下期节目之前，请注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs, when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇特的现代世界中，建立精神坚韧度、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的幸存者。收听《2%》。即 TWO%。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。《回看播客》。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
对于1979年来说，那对我来说是个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? Listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看播客》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难学习》。这个空间关注的是黑人男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都极其不安全、无法坦诚的诚实对话，但你是在和一个懂行的持证专业人士交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做，在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens,
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个同性恋。迈克尔·兰吉尼（Michael Ranjini）。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens），
finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《深陷爱河》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》。这是一个 iHeart 播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。